take a look at the story we got this
from the daily mail alec chose to play
russian roulette rust script supervisor
breaks down in tears as she sues baldwin
over helena hutchins death because he
cocked and fired the gun even though the
scene didn't call for it she says
baldwin knew the gun should have never
been given to him and that he could not
rely on the assistant director about
whether or not the gun was safe to use
mr baldwin chose to play russian
roulette when he fired a gun without
checking it without having an armorer
within his presence i wanna i wanna
point something out this is what i was
saying
uh last a couple weeks ago everybody
started this story saying it was a
misfire from a blank that shrapnel hit
this woman and i wonder i can't remember
who was telling us this but maybe that
was a pr response a crisis management
company for him leaked that story
because they're like if we start with
the premise that was an accident
everyone will believe it was an accident
no matter what and last week i said why
are we assuming it's an accident alec
bought we'd have to assume the armor was
screwed up the assistant director
screwed up that alec baldwin screwed up
and then he pointed in the right
direction those are all crazy
assumptions how come we're not starting
from alec baldwin pulled the gun pointed
it cocked it pulled the trigger and then
from there we can walk it back
now
this is big the script supervisor the
person who knows exactly what's supposed
to go on on on scene says
he wasn't supposed to have a gun right
he should have checked it and he didn't
he certainly wasn't supposed to pull the
hammer and pull the trigger that to me
sounds like a good argument for
intentional homicide
i'm not a huge gun person but every time
i've handled the gun the person handing
it to me who's actually a gun expert or
just someone who's aficionado gave me a
speech and part of that speech is you do
not point a gun at anything that you do
not want to destroy you assume every
single gun you are handing it is loaded
until you check it personally you do not
put your finger on a trigger and if you
screw up any one of those you're still
going to be safe and then just one more
you don't act like a state prosecutor
no no but there is actually one more
always know what's behind your target
okay yeah what your target is and beyond
that's important here specifically for
baldwin because if we're still operating
under the premise that he was pointing
at the camera for a scene he wasn't
paying attention to what was beyond his
target but i don't buy that for a minute
look
if if we're going to talk about a guy
who wasn't supposed to be given a gun
she says she's a script supervisor
that's that's big wasn't supposed to
have it why did he have it why am i then
going to assume this wasn't murder
because you've got an angry crew
you've got people threatening to walk
off set baldwin says i had a dinner with
her just that friday
sounds to me and i said this before
she was actually negotiating him with
him or arguing with him and then he goes
on set takes the gun and says bam
oh oh no oh geez that's like pure psycho
if he did but you're saying that the
rumor that went around that he jokingly
said how about i just kill you both that
that was a false rule yeah yes someone
someone that was clever it was a clever
hoax i almost fell for that one too me
too i actually recorded a video and then
someone responded with the clip and i
was like whoa cause i'm like i'm like
showing the article i'm showing the
tweet and then i see that and i was like
i don't know that's true i gotta check
someone took a news article and then
uh altered the code to add that line
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if it was
his pr team in order to muddy the waters
because a lot of times with this
information we see fake information
being brought out to the general public
to make everyone confused about what's
really going on there and you still i
saw baldwin why not right after the
incident he was right on the phone he
was probably talking to his pr people he
was trying to probably run cover he has
a lot of money he has a lot of influence
and there was a lot of cover we're just
finding out finding out about these
details now how many days later has it
been yeah so what else are they hiding
what else don't we know about when's the
investigation is there even an
investigation i mean what's going on
here everyone should be asking these
larger questions and they're not an
accident means different things right
there's if they're trying to make it out
as if he like just dropped a gun and it
like went off and showed someone when
you are pointing a gun at someone and
cocking a trigger you can't say that
that's an accident that's dimensionality
see i don't even know the terms but even
i know enough you don't point a gun at
someone but so this is this is three
steps actually it's four he drew the
weapon
he then pointed it he then pulled the
hammer back he then pulled the trigger i
mean that is very intentional
yeah it's very disturbing too and it's
also disturbing how many people were on
their knees
running interference for him immediately
conservatives especially is that right
oh yeah you get the whole conservative
oh it's such a tragedy i can't believe
don jr is politicizing
it it's just like the spend cycle and
the pr thing you said i know was true
because i tweeted out man this is really
weird the engagement that i got any time
he tweeted about baldwin hundreds of
replies instantaneously and it was all
you're cruel you're vile yeah how dare
he's he's the victim here yeah yeah it's
amazing yeah and then you even had
conservatives going along oh it's just
such a tragedy no you know what it well
it's tragic for the woman of course
obviously but they were definitely
influencing the conversation and then i
do believe they use this information via
that article because then they would go
conspiracy theorists they're trying to p
gate alec baldwin can you believe it
look at these bad actors blah blah blah
i don't know if you know the answer to
this question um
but
is pointing a gun at someone a felony
it's called brandishing as a legal term
branching of firearm and it definitely
depends on the context so if i were just
here with you guys and one of you you
know brandished a firearm without some
kind of intent
then it wouldn't be but it all depends
on the context but then if you came
to uh to a bank and you just tapped a
gun that would be brandishing even
though you're not even pointing it yes
it was all based on the context and it
also depends on the state laws because
in some states like ohio what the state
prosecutor did in the kyle right in the
house case that's a charge of wisconsin
um
no no ohio has a specific rule oh i see
if if he would have done the same thing
in that state he would have gone down
for a charge right so here's what i ask
we have this from
law.justice.com this is new mexico
statutes on homicide section on
manslaughter and it says voluntary
manslaughter consists of manslaughter
committed upon a sudden quarrel or in
the heat of passion whoever commits
voluntary manslaughter so i don't think
that would apply here they say
involuntary manslaughter consists of
manslaughter committed in the commission
of an unlawful act not amounting to a
felony or in the commission of an uh of
a lawful act which might produce death
in an unlawful manner
uh uh or without due caution or
circumspect
that's a fact they're both felonies and
the reason i ask is i'm wondering if by
simple first we can't call it an
accident an accident would be like you
said you drop it and it goes off and
you're like oh no and you might still
get in trouble because you're
responsible for that but this is a guy
who pulled it out and aimed at the woman
if is so can we even argue this is
manslaughter if he pointed the gun at
her and pulled the trigger you would
some voluntary manslaughter
so the way they would say they could say
well an accident is still negligent so
the legal term is an accident's
negligence so you get in a car crash
it's an accident but who was negligent
were you looking at your cell phone at
the time so involuntary manslaughter the
textbook case of that is if you're
drinking and driving
it isn't a felony to drink and drive but
somebody dies you didn't intend for them
to die so that's usually when that would
apply there was no intent for you to do
gross bodily harm or injury to someone
else so with the alec baldwin case we
don't have enough
facts to know whether it would be
voluntary or involuntary because and you
there's a whole i mean you could do a
whole week of this in law school and
then there's all kinds of cases on it
where you go from
what's the difference between reckless
versus negligent what's the difference
between willful
and again negligent and there's a lot of
things that depend on the facts so i
would
my instinct from day one was that it
would have been involuntary manslaughter
he was
recklessly
he was acting with callous or reckless
disregard for another person's safety
but i don't think he actually wanted to
murder her or anything like that i don't
think he was pointing it at her i think
he was being
alec baldwin who yeah is a
douchebag idiot well with rage issues
yeah as we know but uh uh george clooney
he had a very interesting comment about
this he's usually a globalist stooge but
today he says
it's true
it's absolutely true i mean look what he
pushes uh but he came out and it was
talking about the specific case and said
that it was infuriating and insane that
this happened as he's accusing alec
baldwin baldwin of ignoring decades of
laws regarding safety and firearms on
set of movies so even george clooney
he's coming out calling him out saying
he wasn't doing what he was supposed to
do there's something here that's not
right and adam baldwin also collaborate
corroborated that he said a few weeks
ago i know there's no love lost between
the two brothers he goes i've been on
movie sets and for there's a process for
decades that people go through before
you're handed a gun because and this is
something that gun advocates talk about
all the time even though the anti-gun
people don't say this they know very
well a gun is not a toy you are handling
a weapon that is can kill someone and
you have to treat that with the respect
it is due
so uh let me let me start from from from
this uh premise for you uh cernovich
a man who has decades of firearms
training
is on set
he has no there is nothing calling for
for brandishing displaying or even
holding a weapon
he then points it with a live round and
shoots and kills a woman that i mean
wouldn't an investigator or a d.a go
straight for intentional homicide no
that would be voluntary manslaughter
because that would be reckless versus
negligent you're still not an
intentional murderer because he didn't
intend to kill someone wait but there
but there's no reason to have a gun if i
walk out in the middle of the street and
pull out a gun and shoot somebody
they're going to say intentional
homicide right if
a again it varies in the context how big
was the crowd were you celebrating a uh
fiesta
let's see this i walk into the middle of
the street and there's a person filming
me with a camera i pull out a gun [ __ ]
the hammer shoot him and kill him oh
yeah that would be intentional murder
yeah so so alec baldwin i think this is
why i ask if we're approaching it from
the context of he wasn't supposed to
have a gun
that means he walked up pointed the gun
the woman for no reason which he wasn't
supposed to have and decided to shoot
her
why would we operate as if that was like
manslaughter because it's the context of
the relationship it's the same thing
where
if you were on a first date with a girl
and she fell asleep and you you know
looked for some action that would be
sexual assault potentially but if it's
your wife or your girlfriend then
there's a consent a pattern of consent
so it's different because of the
relationship so the law
that's why the law is hard he's in a
dispute with the crew they were
threatening to walk offset well that you
know that would be the case that people
would make in their case would say that
we we have a working relationship that's
existed here he pulled out the gun
he was i see i see yeah yeah so it's
very you get it i mean laws really i
love having these conversations it's all
about getting in the weeds and
everything is about facts and circums
and that's why law drives people crazy
because it's all context based and one
fact can literally change the whole
outcome did you see the clip when alec
baldwin was outside his house like
yelling at reporters and there were two
things that were really clear from that
clip that i found one disturbing one not
disturbing one is he very clearly feels
horrible about this like this is not
something where he went to bed that
night's like it'll be fine he's
disturbed by this as virtually anyone is
who's responsible for killing someone
else but he also clearly feels that
because he's so upset that means he
suffered enough and leave me alone and
that to me is a big problem you don't
get to decide well i feel really bad i'm
suffering shut up and go away that's not
how it works because you did something
that was extremely preventable and one
person is dead as a kid
real quick correction people are
pointing out adam baldwin is not a
baldwin brother oh okay
another thing to really consider here is
that alec baldwin went to anger
management before because of his rage
issues and because of other court
proceedings that he had related to of
course blowing up and getting really
angry and uh you know committing acts of
either harassment or assault against
other people so there is a long history
here of someone who isn't control of his
emotions to the point where he has
sought professional help so that's
another thing that to consider what if
what if he clearly does feel bad about
this but not for her for him like oh man
i got really mad i just i pulled the
trigger i shouldn't have done that but
was he mad it seemed like he was doing
him very matter-of-factly well
he's an actor too he's an actor too so
we have to consider that when he's
portraying he's emotionally i don't
think he's that good of an actor maybe
as jack donaghy was switched
but that's a cartoon character right
right right i think it's very hard to
make the case that
yeah he's not disturbed by seeing
someone he was at least if one of you
right now god forbid something happened
we'd all be you're making assumptions
you're making assumptions that this is
the issue i took with the case initially
we don't know they were friends i didn't
say they were friends even if it's just
some random you almost said they were
friends you're about to say they were
friends alex said they were friends
but what i'm saying is even if it's
someone like you know a person you had
just a conversation with at a party and
in front of you you saw them
get shot and bleed out i think the vast
vast majority of people will be
traumatized for life
especially if you're the one who pulled
the trigger the d.a says they know who
put the bullets in the gun oh yeah that
was something that came out a while ago
so i guess in this case i mean final
thoughts you think they're gonna
actually charge them for anything is
this the stuff that's coming out from
witnesses i say no no no really what's
they're not gonna get a conviction
just some people are above the law yeah
and he alec baldwin would fall into that
category you think they'll charge the
assistant director or the armor so that
i think a lot of money will exchange
hands and
because alec baldwin's gonna owe
millions of dollars to the family you
know because if they're either way if
it's your friend like if you
accidentally killed
the a friend of yours you would go to
the family and be like look dude you
don't have to assume me like what do you
need yeah yeah yeah so so if they're
friends he's writing a big check if
they're not friends he's writing a big
check so if they're really if they
really are friends and the husband's
going to say what good does it do to put
you in jail they're going to go to the
d.a and say i don't want anybody charged
with this we're not going to cooperate
we're going to do the opposite it's
actually really interesting because i'm
sure that probably happens a lot where
someone does commit uh an act that
results in death that should be
criminally charged but the family who
would normally be complaining are just
like no we understand there was an
example you know that we the us has bag
men who go the middle east and when we
accidentally kill children we have write
them out the check to these families and
when if it's a boy they get a lot bigger
of a check than if we accidentally kill
one more girls so this is actually us
and these are your taxes yeah and
there's actuarial tables for how much
you pay off these poor uh people in the
middle east who basically lost their son
or daughter for no reason depending on
what country what neighborhood and the
age of the the child and how many other
siblings they had and it's and it's
this is where your tax dollars are going
yeah this is insane sometimes i wish
this was a cooking show and we could be
like the cherry goes on the whipped
cream and then we all enjoy a nice
strawberry shortcake instead we're like
after they kill the child they send
someone to pay off the family
real real quick yeah real quick also to
us if you're a prosecutor and you have a
case that's going to be hard to prove
anyway so you're a prosecutor you can
file a case that's going to be hard to
prove and then the victim's family says
we don't want you to file it then you're
not going to file it because what do you
gain and it's very hard to make the case
in terms of sensing him that this is
something he would do again right right
right
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you